before we say goodbye let's play a quick
round of truth or dare
because you can ask me anything or dare
me to do anything and we have terry
perry here
hi carrie
hey drew do you know how happy your name
is very no relation to tyler but you
know
well it's giving me joy truth or dare
drew okay
so we had two lovely sisters here
earlier yeah and you give them them uh
ornaments yeah what's one of your
favorite ornaments
during the holiday season
um
it's uh one of my favorites is a
mushroom i was in um northern california
and i was like in a little town
like on like you know
like main street and i bought this
little mushroom and it was one of the
first ornaments i collected and i was
pregnant and i just thought here is
where it begins
so
let's begin
[Applause]
and it's my first ornament that i bought
and it's still my favorite
so thank you for asking me terry perry
no problem drew barrymore and the
happiest of holidays to you
and thank you for choosing to spend your
time with us
we make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]
you